and it was unsuccessful as you see blake
griffin's right hand getting the left
arm of giannis
and obviously they challenged trying to
keep blake griffin in the game
but with giannis shooting so poorly
i would have been reluctant on that one
to challenge and i've never seen someone
get a practice free throw he got the
ball from the official took a practice
free throw
to get a ribbon i think the rule is if
you ever win back-to-back mvps you're
allowed
i've just never seen this well it worked
because he got the first one to go
meanwhile remember frank vogel was
telling us early
in the playoffs how he went about 13
straight games where he didn't even use
his challenge
and decided he needed to change the way
he he did it his analytical people
telling him about hey
it's okay to use it early in the game
most coaches want to save it but often
you never use it and a 10-second
violation
paul anathetico that's the second time
in the playoffs
that he's had that call do you allow 10
seconds once you have the ball
at the free-throw line to shoot it i got
a problem though mike
it's selective you're telling me that
was tim the other ones aren't
so only two times as he shot a free
throw the whole year that's been over 10
and where are they actually counting as
james throws it up yes they're supposed
to count
now sometimes it happens if the opponent
tells the official hey listen he's going
way over you better call it
sometimes then you've seen it done
rarely called mark and we've
[Applause]
lopez misses the three fights for the
rebound bruce brown who's having quite
the second quarter
and to get back to your challenge
non-challenge the most important thing
to me is
you got to be right if i'm trusting my
staff whoever's in charge
that was a blatant foul play for a nice
set of hands there from brook lopez
coming up with a steal the pedocup
struggling from the free-throw line
including a violation now watch gets the
ball you start the 10-second clock
it's rare you see this call but this is
the second time it's happened
in these playoffs that he was called for
a 10-second violation
this one's not just 10 seconds he
clearly goes
way over and the call was made
let's bring in steve javi of course our
resident referee expert
steve when you're officiating it's
obviously a call that officials don't
really want to call
how do you decide when it starts to be
too long how did you handle that
well one thing for sure i didn't start
my count immediately as he touched the
ball
you try to give him a little benefit of
the doubt and you don't want to count
too fast so we don't have a stopwatch as
you just saw a stopwatch on there maybe
they should do that
i don't know but um no you you want to
make sure
it's at least 11 12 13 seconds as you
call it because
one thing you don't want to do is making
it like 8.9 or 9.2 seconds
you refereed over 25 years how many
times did you call that in
in your career it's funny you say that
mike i know at least i called it once
because
at one time shaquille o'neal had a
problem with it also
and i remember calling it on him i think
when he was playing for phoenix
so he was going through the same thing
that giannis has gone through right now
thank you steve